they're what you call your bike bag okay
let me see if I can I'm in fast-forward
rewind and sort of rehearse what this
conversation the idea of function and an
inverse function right we said we've
been dealing with these for quite some
time and I asked you to give me an
example and unsurprisingly the first
thing you reached for the key right
because you was slightly of those that's
not surprising because the name of the
function as info okay so kind of tells
you hey I'm it even this function right
and the whole idea is well if you have
an angle you take sine of that angle it
gives you a particular ratio but if you
have the ratio I should be able to go in
reverse and get the angle back out of it
right
so side X takes an angle HIDs you back a
ratio sine inverse takes a ratio and it
hands you back an angle okay then we
said on this idea of switching what you
put in and what you get out turning it
the other way around we have got oodles
of examples of this right logs and
Exponential's are the classic example
that we looked at most recently but even
better simple stuff like addition
subtraction multiplication division
these kinds of things they all have
their inverses they're things which undo
the process that you went through okay
now under this heading
I need beheading kilometer in between
under this heading I want us to take
from this table a few kind of important
theory pieces I guess like not just the
intuition of my eye this is what it
looks like but what are the important
pointers that we need to get down from
this right
so in those options the first thing I
want to call your mind back here we did
say this but I own and ask you to write
it another thing geometrically the way
the geometry of an inverse functions
works is that we have this green line
that I've drawn in here the green line
b.e
y equals x
and to go from a function to its inverse
function to its inverse and function to
its inverse
what we are doing geometrically is what
in relation to that line we are
reflecting across right the inverse is a
reflection across y cos x now the reason
for that is because that's what the
picture is telling visually
geometrically that's what's going on but
algebraically if we are switching around
in inputs and outputs mathematicians
famously lazy we don't have to say input
and outputs and we give them letters
which one is usually which which we
usually say is the employer which is the
output we would usually say X is the
input right you put that in and then Y
will be whatever results of course we
could switch them around it's somewhat
arbitrary that they're the letters that
were chosen but X is usually our
independent variable and Y depends on it
it's the output okay so our akley before
what we're doing is we're switching
input and output which is x and y now
from such a simple idea many many
important explication flowers and that's
sort of what we're going to explore this
lessers but just before I we talk about
those implications just up the top here
we didn't really talk about the notation
except to notice in passing there's a
minus 1 there
do you remember where that minus one
coherent why do we use that instead of
like say line for inverse it's on the
board where did the basement come from
it came from to Venus right it came for
this index notation any like 2x or 2 to
the minus 1 X okay this is really
important that we get this distinction
because when you see this right there
every other like context the body of
whatever told you are
well that's index notation we do not
think that that
this the answer is the answer is no
please there even though we have
borrowed X notation in this context of
overlooking functions in the investors
just like when sine inverse okay this is
not the reciprocal this is the inverse
okay so notation if f is our original
function then we designate this as the
inverse now please even as you're
reading that to yourself in your head
don't say f to the -1 I would read that
as f inverse X okay in the same way that
you know you read and - and even though
there's no simple there I'll read that
is M Prime
okay this is a it's an operator that
you're running on that's right it's not
actually in X notation we just borrowing
from the attention all right so where
does that take us all right I want to go
back to this algebraic thing you
remember I said there are some
implications that flow out of these
right surprising that these commands
right for instance suppose you have a
function and you know it's domain a
range okay these are important things
and then not difficult to find out for
any of these functions they're quite
easy to determine if you then wanted to
work out the domain and range of its
inverse what would happen flows directly
out of this what's the connection
between the domain range of a function
and the domain and range of its inverse
yeah because I'm switching them right
domain and range simply depend on x and
y now you are swapping x and y then it
stands to reason you will swap domain
and range right so the domain of the
original function becomes the range of
the inverse
and the range of the original function
becomes the domain of the universe now
when you have a look at what we've got
on the board only one of these is a
particularly interesting example and
that would be the exponential function
and the log function what are the domain
and range of the exponential functions
or real it could go any way you like you
can put any x value you like into that
index that's fine and of course the
range that comes along with that is y is
greater than zero you can never get
there as a type behavior right and of
course you can see when you carry over
here what's the domain of the log
functions and it comes from the range
over here the domain of course is X
positive you're never going to hit that
asymptote over there that I haven't
drawn and the range is all real values
of Y does that make sense okay so
there's the first important application